tout ça c'était remué par notre ami il
dit qu'on arrive au bord on a une
surface d'arrachement
qui sont très très bien la plus belle
donc elle a limite à laquelle il s'est
arrêté
avec sa pioche un jour d'octobre 1977
on n'est pas tout à fait au fond
S
[Musique]
de voilà l'histoire de pillage en
archéologie en archéologie sous-marine
il y a plein plein de trucs mais par
contre avec une telle mise en scène tu
vois le gars
il pense à
sa tombe enfin il va il va y avoir des
remords et tout enfin ça c'est vraiment
je sais pas entendu le truc pareil et
probablement que donc il est sous cette
pierre tombale et probablement qu'il est
là et probablement que il y a des il y a
des pièces archéologiques uniques encore
dedans quoi ça on sait pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc là on peut marcher partout
donc voilà la fausse cola
elle paye pas de mine elle n'a aucun
caractère
exceptionnel comme on la voit comme ça
c'est un trou avec des cailloux c'est ce
qui nous reste du de la fosse dans
lequel était déposé le fabuleux trésor
de cobanous alors comment sait-on que
c'est la bonne fosse il y a trois
éléments le premier c'est déjà le plan
que vous allez laisser le pilleur en
nous disant que c'était à temps de
mettre de ce Boissy attends de mettre de
ce bois là et puis surtout dès qu'on a
décapé on a vu qu'il y avait des
pierrailles qui apparaissaient juste
sous la surface de la bourre alors que
ici on a on avait une vingtaine de
centimètres normalement de collusion
plus tardive et troisième élément dans
la fosse c'était vraiment du Gros
Caillou avec de la terre très oranges et
ça c'est vraiment la terre superficielle
qui est qui a servi à reboucher le trou
donc de manière très intéressante et
tout tout bougé on prenait des cailloux
tout bouger comme dans un stade qui a
été bougé récemment
rien ne va rien laisser ce qu'on
espérait c'est que au moins nous laisser
un petit détail ou une capsule de
Coca-Cola ou je sais pas un truc pour
montrer que c'était lui ou un petit
fragment parce que par exemple sur la
tirelire qui est au musée Getty il
manque un pied donc voilà j'avais mis
des cierges pour espérer que vous avez
oublié le pied dedans il nous a pas
oublié le pied de milieu d'attirer
malheureusement si on avait fouillé 6
places sans savoir toute cette histoire
on aurait décapé on aurait trouvé cette
fausse on est bah ouais il y a quelqu'un
qui a creusé un trou récemment peut-être
pour planter un arbre il y a rien dedans
il vient avec un détecteur de métaux la
nuit
et attiré par un bruit des critiques
dans sa dans sa description mais à se
met à fouiller et nous décrit qu'il
découvre à 4 ans de profondeur sous une
tuile posée à plat le premier dépôt
monétaire il a grandi sa fouille il lui
faut en tout 3 nuits il me semble pour
fouiller l'intégralité du dépôt alors il
y passe
alors il suit les objets ils prélèvent
les objets a priori il le fait quand
même de façon assez consciencieuse donc
plusieurs dépôts monétaires trois dépôts
monétaires au total et puis tout un
ensemble de statuts en bronze non au
moins une grande statue de Minerve une
grande statue de mars
pour la statue de Minerve en bronze
massif et puis la statue de mars doit
être 80 cm pour la plus grande puis
après je crois qu'il y a plus d'une
quarantaine de petites statues alors des
animaux des divinités etc et on sait
aujourd'hui que ces statues
en que les plus belles pièces sont
conservées au musée Getty à Malibu aux
États-Unis les propriétaires des
terrains finissent par apprendre que le
lieu de découverte se situerait sur leur
sur leur terrain et souhaitent
si possible faire rapatrier les objets
du patrimoine leur appartement dans les
musées nationaux et dans les musées
régionaux et donc depuis 2019 on a
entrepris des fouilles programmées parce
que si on pouvait identifier précisément
la fosse on pourrait montrer et prouver
la spoliation des biens des
propriétaires et si possible essayer
d'engager des démarches permettant de au
moins de d'obtenir des copies fidèles
que les objets qui sont au musée de
Malibu par exemple proviennent de
preuves directement on a que la
déclaration du pire ça c'est le document
effectivement transmis donc vous voyez
la partie manuscrite donc a signé
d'octobre 2008
voilà bien conscient de l'INT
scientifique inestimables du dépôt de
bronze de courant j'ai longtemps hésité
à le faire connaître etc les
conséquences juridiques donc ça c'est la
partie manuscrite et puis donc signé du
16 octobre et puis derrière il y a la
déclaration de la découverte officielle
donc là vous voyez c'est un texte de
plusieurs pages sur lequel on retrouve
ce qu'on regardait tout à l'heure donc
le croquis de l'assemblage des pièces
sur lequel on va retrouver réflexion
personnelle sur la datation de
l'enfouissement donc on voit il a étudié
toutes les monnaies
il y a passé vraiment vraiment et le
devenir des différentes pièces voilà
donc on a donc là au musée Getty voilà
on t'aboutis aux États-Unis Malibu donc
les pièces sont maintenant connues elles
sont dans le catalogue du Getty il y a
pas de difficulté et donc voilà signé en
présence
archéologue bénévole de du groupe
Nivernais de préhistoire et conservateur
en chef du patrimoine
au Service régional de l'Archéologie
donc
peu de temps après je sais pas si c'est
pas fin 2008 et c'est vraiment se
repentir du découvreur qui est à
l'origine des recherches qu'on fait
maintenant donc je réalise deux
campagnes de prospection géophysiques
donc sur la surface des parcelles avec
deux méthodes une méthode magnétique et
une méthode radar qui nous permet
d'avoir la première image de site et
d'identifier pour la première fois un
sanctuaire à cet emplacement donc là
vous voyez quand même très bien le grand
enclos quadrangulaire qui correspond au
fossé d'enceinte du sanctuaire gaulois
on va avoir
ensuite la prospection radar sur lequel
là au lieu d'identifier le fossé vous
voyez qu'il est totalement invisible ce
qu'on identifie c'est un très beau au
carré un très beau quadrilatère ici avec
un deuxième qui est beaucoup plus àraser
à l'intérieur donc il montre bien un
temple de plan Centris typique des
temples gallo-romains avec sans doute
une ouverture ici on a deux petites
avancées plein est une ouverture à l'est
et le tout enclos encadré par un grand
quadrilatère ici un quadriporte qui
vient fermer l'espace donc ce trésor
correspond manifestement à
l'accumulation des richesses du Temple
pendant tout son fonctionnement et les
plus belles pièces portent la dédicace à
la divinité comme annonce
et qui nous montre que cette divinité
enfin on connaît par défaut maintenant
la divinité qui est honorée dans ce
sanctuaire
au-delà du dépôt évidemment du gros
dépôt découvert dans les années 70 il y
a pas il y a il y a pas énormément de
mobilier métalliques il y en a un petit
peu on a beaucoup de fibules on en a pas
beaucoup cette année on en a eu
énormément l'année dernière quelques
bagues quelques outils quelques petites
épingles en os aussi mais voilà par
rapport à certains sanctuaires de la
région c'est pas c'est pas un site qui
est pauvre mobilier mais c'est pas c'est
pas exceptionnel on est dans quelque
chose d'assez commun ce qui est devenu
de plus en plus intéressant au fil des
années sur ce site c'est ce qu'on
appelle la fin des sanctuaires c'est à
dire qu'est-ce qui se passe à la toute
fin quand les les sanctuaires païens
sont abandonnés et là pour on a vraiment
la chance cette année d'avoir des belles
couches tardives du troisième du
quatrième siècle et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant donc on a une véritable
problématique quand on vient sur sur ces
chantiers de fouilles là on accepte
partie là mais quand on a fouillé
l'année dernière on avait également des
pièces incendiées complètement
effondrées avec toute la toiture encore
en place mais eff dans le sol brûlé ce
qu'on voit devant nous c'est des
fondations des bâtiments mais on a quand
même malgré tout les toitures et les
murs qui sont effondrés qui sont la
conséquence d'une destruction qu'on
suppose alors peut-être pas volontaire
on peut pas le l'affirmer là on voit le
fouilleur qui est en train d'enlever des
pierres qui sont enfiler les unes sur
les autres c'est un mur tout bêtement
qui sait qui est tombé après que la
toiture est brûlée donc on a
l'impression que sur toute la surface du
site il y a eu un incendie global alors
on peut pas savoir si c'est un gamin qui
a joué avec des allumettes ou si les
gens qui ont volontairement détruit le
site mais par contre ce qu'on voit c'est
que c'est synchrone à la même période
que les autres sanctuaires qui ont été
fournis ce qui est intéressant c'est que
les monnaies qui sont associés d'après
l'inventaire du du découvreur avec ce
trésor elle elles sont quelques années
en période mais seulement quelques
années antérieures à cette épisode de
destruction du site
ce qui nous intéressait vraiment dans la
recherche de cette fosse c'était pas
comment dire retrouver la fosse pour se
refaire le film de la découverte d'un
trésor qui a déjà disparu depuis 40 ans
40 ans maintenant mais c'est surtout et
c'est de voir qu'elle est contexte
comment ces dépôts sont-ils mis en place
est-ce que c'est tout bêtement les
prêtres du sang du sanctuaire qui vont
avoir l'habitude d'entreposer dans un
aménagement espèce de cave à réduit
les différents trichesses du sanctuaire
ou est-ce que c'est un instant t on va
cacher tout ce qui appartient à la
divinité pour parce que ça ça commence à
devenir un petit peu
alors l'intérêt de la chose c'est qu'on
cette fausse là elle se situe pas dans
le temple elle se situe pas dans la
partie sacrée du sanctuaire ni même dans
les bâtiments périphériques elle est
repoussée au fin fond d'une cour le long
d'une petite voix qu'on avait déjà
fouillé l'an dernier donc vraiment dans
un espace périphérique du sanctuaire
avec aucun marquage particulier donc ça
fait vraiment coup de bêche sous un
arbre quoi
c'est la sensation que ça donne il y a
aucun aménagement de la fausse il y a
pas de pierre qui ont été disposées on a
l'impression qu'ils ont creusé ça il y a
une espèce de va vite
ce qui est certain c'est que la fin du
quatrième siècle c'est à une période qui
est néfaste pour les pour les païens les
années 355 c'est le dernier empereur
païen c'est Julien II la posta appeler
la posta par les chrétiens et l'empereur
qui suit les empereurs qui suivent
valent Valence Valentinien Théodose sont
des empereurs chrétiens voir chrétiens
extrêmement comment dire
[Musique]
intégriste même pour certains puisque
Théodose c'est celui qui interdira les
cultes païens et ça correspond justement
aux dates qu'on a là donc on a un moyen
de conjonction d'éléments d'indice qui
nous laisse à penser que non seulement
les cultes païens ne sont plus en odeur
de santé son jeu de mots mais qu'en plus
il y a des personnages qui prennent sur
eux ou qui sont mandatés par le pain
l'Empire pour venir détruire ce réseau
de sanctuaires ruraux qui était encore
fortement fréquenté
[Musique]
avec l'ensemble du mobilier la natation
qu'elle a de frappe en tout cas ça
pourrait nous amener des indices à quel
moment ce bâtiment
a été occupé dans dans les derniers
temps
une couronne avec des pics radié
mais le problème des monnaies c'est son
la durée de circulation une monnaie
entre le moment où on était frappé le
moment était perdu
c'est chouette bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et le culte se fait devant le temple sur
un hôtel c'est là que sur les sacrifices
qui est une espèce de communion on
partage avec la divinité un animal
sacrifié qu'on mange donc souvent dans
des pièces annexes d'où l'intérêt
d'avoir des bâtiments annexes à côté de
notre sanctuaire parce qu'il faut
pouvoir manger avec les différents
fidèles lors de fête régulière donc on a
plus aucune idée malheureusement
on les récolte de manière extrêmement
précieuse parce qu'ils vont nous donner
des indices alors sur des pratiques
qu'on pourrait qualifier de profane
quand on mange sur le sanctuaire on est
en train de balayer ou je sais pas quoi
mais l'essentiel des ossements vont
révéler justement ces pratiques
collectives de sacrifices qu'on appelle
les sacrifices sanglants on tue la bête
devant la divinité et puis là-bas on
partage alors la divinité les zones
malheureusement ils peuvent pas manger
les os ils peuvent pas manger les
tendons donc on donne ça la divinité on
les brûle elle elle peut les manger
c'est pratique et puis l'homme lui il
peut manger que la viande donc il se
contente de la viande c'est un partage
des vraisemblablement sanctuaires
d'agglomération et qui devait situer en
périphérie d'une agglomération gauloise
ou gallo-romaine
on a identifié une occupation gauloise
uniquement gauloise juste de l'autre
côté à proximité donc des structures
agricoles que vous voyez là mais
manifestement pas de préoccupation
gallo-romaine
au-dessus de l'agglomération gauloise
donc le fait que ce site soit sanctuaire
il y a une agglomération marche pas bien
si l'agglomération qui est là-bas n'est
contemporaine que de l'époque gauloise
en hélicoptère faire des photos de voir
les agences mens des sites vraiment
vraiment à l'aveugle quoi sans se dire
là on va sûrement trouver un truc juste
on part avec un hélicoptère on tente le
coup vous avez ici ça tombe bien des
plus grands spécialistes en France de ça
puisque pierre nouvelle est en même
temps prospecteur aérien je pensais une
des personnes qui fait le plus
d'archéologie aérienne aujourd'hui en
France
les vestiges enfouillent tout un tas de
traces dans la végétation on connaît le
principe le blé il pousse mal s'il y a
des fondations en dessous ils poussent
beaucoup mieux s'il y a un fossé combien
de bonnes terre donc c'est un principe
extrêmement bien puis 60 70 ans elle a
trouvé des milliers et des milliers de
sites archéologiques de cette façon-là
et en particulier en Bourgogne puisque
la terre est vraiment labourée beaucoup
il y a des céréales donc la photographie
aérienne c'est certainement la méthode
la plus intéressante on en voit environ
800 mille mètres du sol pour avoir une
bonne vision bien globale et on voit les
anomalies se différencier comme ça à
l'ONU on s'aperçoit qu'il y a un site
archéologique tous les 100 m quoi c'est
une densité ferrailleuse faut imaginer
qu'un territoire il était occupé aménagé
il y a des fermes qui ont bougé c'est
quelque chose qu'on a du mal à concevoir
ça parce qu'on a toujours l'impression
aujourd'hui on connaît tous les drones
les machins mais non on a encore au tout
début parce que il y a très peu de
secteurs finalement il y a des
archéologues qui mettent les pieds dans
les bottes pour aller véritablement
étudier des zones rurales alors chacun
de ces secteurs va donner une
information mais il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à découvrir
l'essentiel
ça c'est la campagne de fouille de 2019
donc on a cherché le dépôt à cet endroit
là alors on l'a cherché à cet endroit là
pourquoi il y avait cette tâche blanche
sur le radar Gramm qui nous a fait
penser que ça pouvait être le dépôt avec
encore des matériaux en terre en pierre
à l'intérieur bon c'était pas du tout ça
c'était juste un bac de conservation de
chaud de chaux vive qui était conservée
et là vous voyez la grande tranchée qui
nous a permis de recouper les bâtiments
du temple l'emprise du temple et puis un
petit bout de fossé Gaulois ici un petit
bout de fossé d'époque gauloises là et
décider d'ouvrir
donc là cette année on a fait tout ça
donc la fosse elle est ici là vous
repérez l'endroit où on est en train de
fouiller les fossés et donc nous on
situe caché à peu près par là on
assemble le puzzle et ça nous permet de
recomposer l'image réelle de l'évolution
que ce sanctuaire sur cinq siècles
donc nous sommes à coin
en 2022
ma couche s'appelle
500022 c'est la fausse au nord-ouest
là-bas et cet objet est enregistré sur
le numéro 33 et je vais mettre une
étiquette en place dans la fosse pour
pointer exactement à l'endroit dans la
couche
où je l'ai trouvé et après elle va être
reprise ou de lutte pour le positionner
sur le système informatique géographique
du site voilà je vous expliquerai tout à
l'heure tu peux en détail à quoi elle
sert la mallette du tapiomètre et il
nous manque plus qu'un objet
qui va être le prisme pour faire de la
topographie quelle est la première chose
nécessaire
la question n'est pas de placer
l'appareil au même endroit c'est de
s'assurer que la position où est placé
l'appareil est connu
donc pour ça il faut soit avoir un point
de référence connu tout le temps voir un
deuxième c'est mieux soit un ensemble de
points de référence qui va permettre par
triangulation de positionner et de
connaître la position de l'appareil ok
donc pour faire ça ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'il y ait des points de repère
les cordes avec des coordonnées
géographiques connues autour de nous
ses coordonnées ne bougent pas ouais
alors là vous imaginez une église un
machin une rue des points géodésiques
placés par l'hygiène autour de nous on a
quand même pas des masses donc pour ça
ce qu'on fait quand on vient nous sur le
terrain on emmène ce qu'on appelle un
GPS différentiel qui va nous permettre
de placer des points de référence autour
de notre chantier donc ça je l'ai déjà
fait il y a quelqu'un qui prend ça et
puis on va se déplacer sur l'endroit le
plus approprié pour installer notre
instrument
vous savez très bien qu'on a réfléchi
l'emplacement de la position de la
station au moment même où on a fait
l'étape terre parce que d'expérience si
je l'avais mis là-bas derrière et un
moment je peux pas vider ce qui est dans
le coin ici on s'est dit bah le meilleur
endroit pour placer la station va être
dans le l dans l'angle duel du décapage
donc ici ça va bien le trépied on peut
avoir tendance à avoir envie de le
mettre comme ça là avant
d'accord bon plus vous pouvez écarter
les pieds
or le monter ce qui est rigolo c'est que
il y a Laurine il y a moi donc là il
faut qu'on se retrouve à une hauteur
donc la hauteur de l'instrument en plus
permet à tout le monde de viser et
d'utiliser le même équipement moi si je
la mets là puis qu'on met l'instrument
ici moi je vis tranquille mais Laurine
il faut qu'elle trouve un marche-pied et
vice-versa si on fait comme ça à moi
chaque fois qu'il faut que je vise je me
casse le dos
c'est stable et on foncer un peu les
pieds au cas où
[Applaudissements]
on regarde la bulle et on va faire une
première mise à niveau
[Musique]
en plaçant la bulle au centre
parce que ça pour vous c'est
OK
allez
moi j'ai fait mon job
et la caisse
un tout petit peu dans le sens c'est bon
en général faire ça deux c'est pas la
meilleure solution vaut mieux qu'il y a
un seul cerveau qui tourne les manettes
donc là lui il va démarrer son logiciel
ont toujours un peu de patience c'est
l'informatique moderne c'est inévitable
informatique tout court
voilà tu fais du bruit il est content
on sait que c'est sites sont pour
l'essentiel pillées anciennement vers
les trésors des temples sont pour la
plupart disparus à l'époque médiévale
comme quand pendant les guerres on
rentre dans les églises on pique les
trésors des églises pour en faire quoi
bah soit des richesses les revendre les
refondre faire des armes avec etc ça a
été la même chose au Moyen-âge et
ensuite ceux qui sont passés à travers
ça qui ont été quand même préservés
aujourd'hui ils sont pliés par toutes
les gens qui font de l'archéologie
clandestine au détecteur à métaux
forcément c'est comme ça que ça va le
mieux en tout cas pour les périodiques
et il nous reste très peu donc le fait
aujourd'hui d'avoir une déclaration
voire replacer la découverte d'un trésor
de ce type là dans un sanctuaire un
édifice de cette nature c'est pour nous
important si on a l'impression que de
trouver des bustes en bronze massive
d'empereur c'est une découverte
exceptionnelle en fait pas du tout il y
a ça dans tous les temples et c'est
quelque chose de absolument commun on
n'est pas dans les plus grands
sanctuaires de Gaulle on est sur un
petit sanctuaire rural isolé classique
[Musique]
un sanctuaire de capital de capital de
cité romaine les grands sanctuaires de
Lyon vous imaginez les grands
sanctuaires de Lyon ça c'est autre chose
que perdu sur le bord du territoire et
duen
en pleine campagne donc quand on parle
de piège aujourd'hui c'est des sites qui
vont livrer plusieurs milliers de
monnaies au détecteur à métaux et on a
vu au mois de mon expérience j'ai déjà
vu des gens traverser l'Europe et on
retrouve trois quatre grosses voitures
ils viennent pas je vous rassure ils
viennent pas en deux chevaux c'est
vraiment des très gros véhicules mais
ils font 1000 monnaies gauloises par
soir ou dans l'année dans la saison
alors bah oui forcément il y a certains
sites c'est c'est quantité là qui sont
en jeu donc par contre pour y coller 10
milles monnaies d'or gauloise trouvée
sur un dépôt ben ça se vend pas
n'importe qui donc là il y a des réseaux
de marchands derrière et finalement
c'est peut-être ça qui est le plus
dramatique dans l'histoire du péage de
cours c'est les réseaux qui sont en
marche derrière c'est les marchands
c'est les gens qui vont transiter le
marché du patrimoine quand le Getty
achète un marchand parisien il y a un
acte de vente voilà donc un moment on
passe dans une fille plus ou moins
officielle puis on oublie la
clandestinité qui est derrière et c'est
peut-être ça le plus le plus regrettable
dans dans le piège aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le maillage de bénévoles
n'existe plus dans les campagnes il est
présent dans le préventif avec des
personnes tout à fait exceptionnelles et
des organismes qui fonctionnent très
bien mais avant dans chaque village il y
avait un bénévole qui était plus ou
moins le relais de l'arc du Service
régional de archéologie ça veut dire que
pour des jeunes aujourd'hui qui sont
dans un paysage comme ici dans une
petite commune ils vont pas avoir la
possibilité de rencontrer des
archéologues professionnels qui vont
leur apprendre la manière de faire à
l'inverse dans chaque village il y a un
ou deux pilleurs au détecteurs à métaux
qui vont rapidement rencontrer et
finalement c'est beaucoup plus facile de
rencontrer dans nos campagnes un pieur
que un vrai archéologue et j'ai crainte
que beaucoup de gens qui se redevenir
des brillants archéologues se sont en
fait devenus des pilleurs parce que il y
avait pas ses relais de l'archéologie
officielle quoi n'importe quel bénévole
moi j'ai des collègues qui font tout un
tas de travail qui sont paysans qui sont
directeurs de d'Intermarché j'en passe
et des meilleurs qui ont des
autorisations de fouille ou de
prospection officielle et qui rendent
des rapports de qualité ils sont
reconnus comme des le tout c'est d'avoir
le temps les réseaux sur toute
collaboration la formation initiale pour
le faire alors c'est un coup de chance
terrible c'est que voilà je rappelle
c'était en 6e je racontais toute ma vie
j'étais en sixième mais le bus il devait
faire tout un tas de villages avant de
m'emmener chez moi alors que j'étais
j'habitais à 2 km du collège donc je
traversais les champs avec mon sac à dos
en traversant j'ai trouvé des choses par
terre qui était curieux moi j'ai montré
ça mes parents qui me diras mais donc ça
à la poubelle c'est aucun intérêt puis
quand même j'avais déjà lu pas mal de
bouquins d'archéo je me doutais que
c'était intéressant je suis allé voir
mon prof d'histoire coup de chance il
avait il était deux parties d'un
programme de recherche et une
autorisation de prospection déjà à
l'époque il existait François Jean roux
s'appelait et il m'a dit mais si si ça
c'est une vache police ça c'est une
fibule romaine ça c'est une monnaie et
je me suis dit mais mince on peut
trouver des objets archéologiques il y a
des sites archéologiques et là il m'a
dit ah bah oui pas de problème on a un
club archéologique qui autorisé on fait
des prospections tous les mercredis nous
emmener dans sa R12 et donc on a
prospecté comme ça une multitude de de
territoire ça fait l'objet de rapport et
j'ai appris à connaître la la
l'archéologie program Mée comme ça on
perd me déposer je fouillait
certainement très très mal et là j'ai
commencé à créer des gens puis après
voilà c'était parti c'était mort quoi
beaucoup trop non pas du tout ça fait
pas beaucoup trop c'est assez étonnant
parce que des fois on raisonne quasiment
avec le même cerveau partagé on a
commencé de travailler ensemble en
donc oui ça fait déjà quelques années ça
fait quoi ça fait 23 ans 24 ans
donc on a de grandes habitudes de
travail tous les deux ça marche très
bien on est pas tout à fait au fond
j'y crois pas mais bon
[Musique]
il faut lui faire croire sinon on l'a
pas creuser
[Musique]
en plus de l'intérêt scientifique qu'on
va porter au site il y a vraiment une
dimension policière et digmatique
mystérieuse qui fait un petit peu rêver
tout le monde il y a encore des mystères
qui planent autour de ça on sait qu'il y
a certains éléments qui ne sont pas
listés on sait qu'il y a certaines
pièces qui ne sont pas dans certains
musées dont on a pu trace c'est qu'il a
gardé certaines pièces par deux vers lui
et on sait pas ce qu'il en a fait après
sa mort
il est fort probable que le découvreur
donc monsieur Colas et décidé de se
faire enterrer
clandestinement dans l'Aveyron dans un
ancien cimetière médiéval et il serait
enterré sous une pierre tombale qui l'a
fait inscrire avec les dédicaces à
kobanous
donc c'est une sépulture illégale dans
un site patrimonial
c'est interdit de le faire également que
tout le mystère trône autour de
saintetons même et quand je dis qu'il y
a eu en quête des travaux judiciaires en
cours c'est que on peut pas faire ouvrir
une tombe comme ça
n'importe comment donc il faut déjà
obtenir des autorisations pour aller
vérifier ou non si il est bien dedans
avec oui il s'est fait enterré comment
ça marche on a appris récemment
d'une collègue qui aurait été je dirais
en contact avec lui du temps de son
vivant pour étudier une partie des
monnaies qu'il a fini sa vie en vivant
misérablement il a pas fait fortune en
vendant le trésor
est-ce qu'il y a des regrets des remords
est-ce que c'est ça qui l'a amené un
moment ou un autre à faire cette
déclaration et à vouloir faire
amandonnorable peut-être et je crois
qu'il a vécu une partie de la fin de sa
vie comme ça en idéalisant en rêvant
cette découverte alors qu'au final cette
découverte elle a du sens que là qu'au
bord du chantier que dans son contexte
dans son ensemble mais ça c'est c'est ça
qui rend cette cette redécouverte
fabuleuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais chiot
à la grande Rivoire
le plus cette fois trial du massif et
c'est l'un des principaux accès sur les
plateaux du Vercors c'est un abri sous
roche naturel c'est un site qui a une
histoire sédimentaire vraiment vraiment
importante pour vous dire là on est on
est à 6000 avant Jésus-Christ alors que
là on est à 85
99% de la vie de l'homme moderne
et je vais vous laisser me les mettre
dans l'ordre chronologique parce que on
les imagine toujours tu sais qui
survivent qui sont là à crever la dalle
à essayer de chasser le moins de
bestioles pour manger le crâne le corps
de l'animal plus les chair et la peau
avec les poils ça devait faire comme une
bonne bête c'est intéressant c'est de
voir comment je pouvais faire avec
de notre point de vue pas grand chose
[Musique]